in every good mythological story there
is always a villain an entity that
threatens chaos and destruction the
knoweth will end of everything we know
when we take a look at Egyptian
mythology that evil takes the form of
Apophis or a pep the god of chaos
darkness and destruction he was known by
several names including a pepper Popeye
and the Greek translation of Apophis in
some of the earliest stories Apophis was
once the God of the Sun he was later
pushed aside by rah the God that we will
come to associate with the Sun today
having been somewhat dethroned by rah
Apophis harbored a great deal of
resentment towards the God and he vowed
to make it as difficult as possible for
rod succeed in his task of bringing the
dawn every day in some depictions
Apophis was born from darkness and chaos
making him the mortal enemy of light and
fueling his desire to overthrow the
balance of all things
Apophis takes a form of an enormous
serpent of a 50 feet long which is why
he earned the nicknames evil lizard and
serpent from the Nile the word a pep is
derived from the Egyptian word meaning
slither and could also be used as a term
for being spat out which would refer to
the way Apophis was shunned and removed
from his position as God of the Sun
there are even some depictions of
Apophis being described as a crocodile
that swims in the dark waters of the
underworld in later Greek and Roman
stories he was described as an enormous
golden snake several miles long the head
of stone Apophis was just one of the
many gods to have been born from the
goddess Neith making him brother to many
of the predominant gods in Egypt
including raw saket and Sobek every day
when raw would travel across the sky in
he so lebarge bringing the dawn Apophis
would await to attack the Sun God in an
attempt to plunge the world into
darkness
as a result I enlisted the help of
numerous defenders that will make their
journey with him when Apophis would show
up to block the way they would slit the
belly of the serpent open allowing rah
to pass there is a story regarding the
two where one morning raw was performing
his duties when Apophis swallowed the
barge whole raw transformed himself into
a cat and moved the help of set they
were able to cut themselves free from
inside Apophis and continue their
journey with cats and snakes being seen
as natural enemies the story of raw
transforming into a cat to defeat his
nemesis doesn't make sense from a
symbolic standpoint in other stories
Apophis would hypnotize raw and all of
his followers only the God set would be
able to resist the serpent and he would
repel him of his great spear despite
being defeated every day Apophis
continued to swallow the Sun God and his
followers knowing that if they were
unable to escape just once he would
succeed and plunge the world into
darkness despite being considered a god
Apophis was rarely worshipped by anyone
there was even a book solely dedicated
to stop in the serpent God which
included a collection of rituals meant
to keep him at bay
the people of Egypt believed that
Apophis would lead an army of demons
that would prey upon the living and the
dead each year in order to stop this the
priests of Ross temple would conduct an
annual ritual known as the banishing of
a pep an effigy of the serpent God was
taken into the temple and imbued of all
the evil of the land the effigy was then
beaten cursed and burnt to keep a puffs
away and help the gods ensure that the
Sun would rise again the next day the
book containing his rituals and magic
spells devoted to stop in him was known
as the book of Apophis
I hope you guys enjoy taking another
look at some Egyptian mythology if you
did let me know in the comments below
what you thought but as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained